three
there's a drive kawhi dumps it on the
wing picked up by jackson into jamaica
green
no foul good defense by the waker he's
knocked down
three triples on top lebron is there
george splits the d drives leads got him
nice play by paul george kawhi will
dance kuzma defends knocked away
kuzma good d george picks it up puts up
a three
what a shot by paul george lebron
against green
shot clock at six no help here lebron
puts it up in town james is 14 points
again look at the late rotation and if
you're reggie jackson you got to get
offensively by the clippers
leonard and james comes out on him sham
it with a screen and james sticks right
with kawhi
he hits leonard shot clock at five
shamit trying to feed in the corner
knocked away by caruso
oh great defense here and then here's
caruso with this
oh the deflection and still leonard he
has gone
three or four from three lebron will
meet him up high
here's george he's gone five of nine
that shot good
it's a three and it ties the game at
101.
nice little step back three here for pg
13.
six threes by paul george four second
difference lebron on the fly got his own
miss
and puts it up and in lebron james
gives the lakers the lead collectively
in this country
two terrific games on tnt going right
down to the wire you see the clock
lebron on kauai down to four here's
george he's way outside
a lunging three no rebound caruso
that's it lakers of one
the two best clipper players lebron
james
shuts them both down ali's a six-time
all-defensive selection lebron james
probably gets
voted there again